I would still describe myself as as a
fairly staunch libertarian sort of
meaning that I'm not very much in favor
of free market economics um probably
quite a little bit more liberal on those
opposed to social issues and and and I
believe basically that individual
freedom is is very important on and that
we live in a world in the 21st century
where there will either be a lot more or
a lot less and that that the politics
matter and ideas matter because the
choices people make will will be of
decisive importance in determining you
know how the 21st century is going to
shape up you know the 20th century was
sort of a great and a terrible century
at the same time and I think the 21st
has has every indication of being far
greater and far more terrible
well I think the alternative is just
very ugly and I think the alternative to
it is is something where you know
people's you know in a in a lot of
context people's people's personalities
get distorted their views get stifled in
an economic context prosperity gets
destroyed which you know may not always
seem to be that important to people but
I think in the long run does matter a
tremendous amount and and then I do
think that that you know it you sort of
you know these are the extreme opposite
to it is uh is just sort of this sort of
incredibly violent sort of
totalitarianism that we've seen you know
the 20th century both in sort of a in
all sorts of different forms that it's
taken and that that seems to me is uh
it's just uh it's just very very
undesirable and I I you know it's and I
do see them as being um sort of
different ends of the spectrum on and
that to some extent we always we always
need to preserve a fight for individual
freedom I think that there obviously the
u.s. there's a lot of people have a lot
of freedom and at the same time there
are a lot of ways in which it's not
entirely free country and and people
tend not to be fully aware of the ways
in which it is both very special and
very free as well as the ways in which
it is not people tend to just be very
complacent and accept whatever the
status quo is as more or less of what
the world is going to be like a plus or
minus 2% or whatever and I think that
the range of possibilities is just much
greater
certainly our many dimensions to it you
know the university setting is one where
I think a lot of important ideas are
never even discussed so it's not that
you know once you have a discussion you
hear both sides is that you do not even
have a discussion so there are there are
topics questions debates that are that
are not being not being had you can
probably come up with an enormously long
list of those but but it but it's not
entirely obvious what it is it's not
being discussed that maybe maybe is very
important you know I think certainly uh
in the sort of one of my one of my
standard complaints in the in the in the
public policy sphere is that we you know
we have a semi socialist healthcare
system which i think is extraordinarily
broken and people people don't realize
just how bad it is and how you know
people get these sort of very
perfunctory checkups from doctors we're
not really getting paid anymore you know
the tort law system is further
constrained freedom up
we can't experiment with new drugs new
treatments for for for for ill patients
so I think the sort of the sort of is a
counterfactual world where things could
be vastly better and but it requires one
to have a bit of imagination to see that